these researchers have been on the go
for days looking for Saiga's across the
vast grasslands of the Kazakh steppe the
greatest challenge is finding the
animals because their population is now
much smaller and we don't know exactly
where they are we sighted them when we
took a cam
two weeks ago but afterwards they went
elsewhere no one has seen them since
then the territory is just incredibly
large the protected area is as large as
France it's like looking for a needle in
a haystack
after the mass die-off last year the
Saiga antelope population was decimated
here alone in the largest sangha
population more than 200 thousand
animals died 90% were wiped out in a
matter of days
it's fine the moment at Xena hum
disappeared you stabbed me I was shocked
I was in the field myself and saw with
my own eyes the first dead Saiga's lying
there it was the first place where it
had and I was right there waiting for
five thousand animals are buried under
this hill it's the first time Stephan
Ceuta and the British Antelope
specialist Richard Kok have returned
since the great die-off they want to
find out why so many Saiga's died the
Pasteurella bacterium which led to the
deaths has been identified the
researchers also know that before the
die-off there was a huge drop in
temperature and the animals were very
stressed
they lost their coat they don't have
their winter coat so the stress in
combination with exposure to bacteria or
the presence of bacteria leads to the
invasion of the bacteria into the body
and rapid death / acute 5 hours you know
12 hours
there have often been mass deaths among
Saiga antelopes but never of such
magnitude why did all of the infected
animals die and how could the disease
break out in different places at once
the expedition aims to shed light on
that but first the researchers have to
find the animals
day four of the search a meeting with
Rangers they're supposed to lead the
expedition to the Saiga's but there's a
problem
the only two animals with radio collars
have separated from the herd they said
that here in the region there are only
small groups of Saiga's left you can see
them but not getting near know Saiga's
far and wide
only mosquitoes are here all the time
and everywhere frustration builds after
four unsuccessful days of searching but
then the next morning there's a glimmer
of hope it's like a footprints here
fresh
right you can see you know they're here
so we have footprints now so it's not
far they are extraordinary animals the
way they move
obviously carving is the only time that
we can really get anywhere near them
animal runs at 70 kilometers per hour
Stephane tells me they'll run 100
kilometers in one day
the Saiga footprints haven't helped the
search is increasingly becoming a test
of patience
and time and again new setbacks its
range too much recently
the fear is that the place where Stefan
and Richard suspect the large herd might
be is inaccessible
another day without success so we find a
place to camp erect our tents and hope
the next day something happens that no
one had expected anymore the spirits of
the steppe are there the expedition has
achieved its aim now we finally found
Saiga
we've traveled a long way they've hidden
in a place that's very hard to reach on
our way we've seen that there are now at
least 2,000 Saiga's the animals have
gathered a thousand kilometres deep in
the steppe to bear their young
most of the calves are already on their
legs and they're evidently doing well
now the scientists can start the real
work that includes weighing and
measuring the calves we want to carry
out conventional monitoring on the state
of the cards in other words to find out
how many there are the density of the
calf population in order to see how
reproduction is going a tissue sample
should show whether there are
Pasteurella bacteria in the calves
bodies the usually harmless bacteria
that became lethal pathogens last year
killing all the animals basically where
we were 10 years ago and these mass
die-offs can happen again to preserve
this species it's very important to
understand just what happened and
whether anything can be done to combat
it
despite the extreme environment poaching
and mass mortality Kazakhstan's ancient
animal has survived for millennia but
conservationists are worried that
another mass die-off could be the last